we see this morning susan collins
says oh democrats and republicans
there's some common ground apparently
susan collins thinks that guns have
learned their lesson learn their [ __ ]
lesson just like the rest of the people
that she capitulates to makes excuses
for susan collins we don't care about
your common ground that's not what we're
concerned about we're not concerned
about common ground in the senate
between republicans and democrats
there's plenty of common ground out here
90 percent you dumb [ __ ] 90
of people are for a bill that your
caucus is blocking you republicans
common ground my [ __ ] ass a grocery
store a church
an elementary school
a hospital what next restaurant now
we've had those movie theater ah we had
those two what next where to next common
ground it's good thing bunch you
senators republicans have decided that
there's common ground somewhere and
these guns has learned their lesson it
really is not difficult and it gets
easier and easier every day to see
exactly what is happening because there
was a question about this gun what kind
of gun is it is it shotgun is it a rifle
is it a handgun what kind of gun is it
what kind of gun is it the media is
waiting the media's waiting politicians
are waiting to find out if this is a
military of course it's a military-style
weapon what in the why the [ __ ] would
someone take any other kind of gun into
a shooting to kill multiple people why
why would they do that that's like
taking a 1992 dodge caravan to a drag
race the [ __ ] are you talking about of
course of course they're going to get
the best weapon they can to apply the
maximum amount of damage that's the
point well they're mentally ill yeah
probably you're not gonna do anything
about that either common ground susan
collins you dumb [ __ ] if you
want more of a reason i don't know to
participate in your democracy and figure
out how can we work this around where
the majority of ideology right the
majority of american opinion on policy
not opinion anyways just on policy like
i don't know common sense gun safety
just common [ __ ] sense we did a whole
show on it yesterday you're killing us
by putting these [ __ ] weapons in the
hands of people who should not have them
how in the [ __ ] can't we figure this out
doors dildos it's porn matt walsh wants
to blame it on lgbtq community
destroying our country monkey pots all
kinds of [ __ ] nonsense it's the gun
you dumb [ __ ] it's the [ __ ]
gun it is not difficult to understand
what is happening in this country it is
not tony there's other country that have
these guns that don't have these
problems they just they don't they ban
back doors in porn they don't have porn
they don't have dildos they don't have
condoms life begins at a boner and women
can't vote don't you know this that's
what we need to do in this country you
understand what they're trying to do
right you get it right you understand
what these fascists are trying to do
like matt walsh tucker carlson greg
abbott ron desantis they're using your
fear and your arguments for guns to do
nothing to spiral us into fascism a lot
[ __ ] quicker by blaming it on porn
and dildos and trans people and wokism
and woke teachers and snowflakes as if
they're not the biggest snowflakes in
the entire [ __ ] world get the [ __ ]
out of here with that [ __ ] it is the
access to the gun the gun the gun the
gun the gun you dumb [ __ ] how
can you tie fascism to people who just
want their second amendment right it's
not your second amendment right it is
not your second amendment right to have
the weapons to go into a hospital a
grocery store a school a church a
theater a restaurant a bowling alley an
office building a post office a
community center it is not your [ __ ]
right to access that gun as fast as
possible so you can go kill as many as
possible you are [ __ ] deluded you are
deranged you are a [ __ ] idiot pluck
your [ __ ] head out of your goddamn
ass